the us government has released a secret
intelligence report that finds the saudi
crown prince responsible for approving
the murder
of the journalist jamal khashoggi mr
khashoggi disappeared in 2018
after entering the saudi consulate in
istanbul
where he is believed to have been killed
and dismembered
our defense and security correspondent
aleister bunkel joins me now from
washington uh alistair no big surprise
but nonetheless still very significant
this report
yeah i think you're right i mean i don't
think there's anything much in the
report that we didn't already
know but what it does is it puts on
public record
the cia in particular their assessment
that it was mohammed bin salman
who was behind the community of killian
jamal khashoggi
back in 2018 he was the one who
authorized
the action of the team that went to
istanbul and
ultimately killed the saudi journalist
the report
makes that clear in no uncertain terms
but it does outline
some of the reasons why the cia have
come to that assessment and just one of
them i'll read out
uh says that the team included seven
members of mohammed bin salman's elite
personal protective detail
known as the rapid intervention force
the rapid intervention force
exists to defend the crown prince
answers only to him
and had directly participated in earlier
dissident suppression operations in the
kingdom at saudi arabia
and abroad at the crown prince's
direction so it's pretty unequivocal
in that respect as i say it doesn't
really
tell us anything that most people didn't
expect anyway but it does signal
you know really quite a a sizable shift
in approach to saudi arabia from the
united states
under president biden for many years
through many presidencies
um saudi arabia has been a key middle
east ally for
important strategic and security reasons
including it should be said during the
obama administration president obama uh
mohammed bin salman
donald trump was very cozy with the
the saudi administration uh during his
tenure but
president biden has made it very clear
he's going to take a very different
approach
he will speak only to king salman not
muhammad bin salman he is described
before saudi arabia
as a prior state he has stopped
funding arms sales for saudi arabia
because of their use in yemen
and now he must decide having published
this report
what kind of action he is going to take
against the crown prince and what effect
that might have
on diplomatic relations